[Musique]
alors on est en train avec laurent
brunet le directeur de versailles
spectacles de regarder un extrait du
spectacle pyrotechnique sur marie
antoinette qui a lieu pour la troisième
année qui aura lieu pour la troisième
année au mode juillet oui c'était
l'occasion parce que c'est
l'anniversaire de l'arrivée de marie
antoinette à versailles
l'anniversaire de son mariage et de son
on va dire de son être comme reine de
france
1770 2022 reprendre pour la dernière
fois ce spectacle dont stéphane bern
fait la voix le commentaire et qui
illustre assez bien voilà les l'histoire
de cette reine de france
c'est un petit peu un personnage
mythique de notre histoire mais aussi
beaucoup de l'historiographie du compte
à l'étranger notamment les américains et
asiatiques voit en elle une espèce de
lady diana du 20e siècle et c'est un
spectacle pyrotechnique ses superbes
enfin oui le travail que fait groupe f
qui réalisent régulièrement à la tour
eiffel au burj khalifa enfin bref dans
le tous les plus grands lieux du monde
des grands spectacles pyrotechniques et
alors on leur donne à la contrainte de
le faire à versa dans un site qui est
aussi historique donc fragile et il
faudrait pas mettre le feu au château de
versailles prêts à essayer donc on
trouve le moyen pour les deux et de
raconter une histoire passionnée d'art
et d'histoire
alors voilà on raconte ya vraiment du
début à la fin on va dire le personnage
et son contexte historique et incluant
bien sûr à la fois les beautés de
versailles mais aussi la révolution est
évidemment pour faire tout ça bon bain
le feu la flamme l'explosif sont des
éléments de travail
alors ça fait partie des grands
spectacles de versailles un janaina
beaucoup et qui succéderait d'ailleurs
un très grand plus il un large public
oui on fait à peu près pour 1 million
600 mille spectateurs dans l'année des
spectacles qu'on dirait nous grand
public c'est à dire à la fois ce
spectacle pyrotechnique sur gradins qui
est marie antoinette
mais aussi les grands dangers des grands
tôt voilà les grandes eaux c'est
vraiment une tradition c'est plus de 350
ans maintenant de mise en eau des
fontaines du jardin versailles pour un
public sélectionné à l'art au début le
roi était un peu tout seul mais faut
dire que le réseau
un peu d'eau il fallait de construire
assez vite qui est beaucoup de
courtisans puis c'est devenu un rendez
vous majeur
chaque dimanche à versailles pendant
tout le 19e siècle aussi et même au
début du 20e siècle on venait d'arriver
pour voir les grandes tendances est une
chose alors ça paraît un peu curieux
aujourd'hui il ya de l'eau dans tous les
ronds-points en france mais l'adduction
d'eau à versailles
ça a été un tiers des ddd début de
dépenses de construction du château un
tiers de jeunes adversaires
c'est le budget de cette fontaine etc
pour celle là que louis xiv a été
détournée l'eau depuis la seyne être le
maître de l'eau c'est une richesse
extraordinaire à l'époque où il ya trois
fontaines puits dont 3 soleil est donc
le maître de l'eau ah oui bien sûr il
est vrai que de tous les éléments il ya
ya ya les gros dos le joug des comptes
d'urnes et les grandes zones nocturne
pour les nocturnes ont fait une mise en
lumière de ces jardins et on termine par
un feu d'artifice mais c'est aussi
l'occasion finalement d'ouvrir les
bosquets déjà en journée mais la nuit
avec un autre rapport il ya on parle on
est l'été est là les senteurs des fleurs
qui sont au moment où elles sont toutes
et klose c'est vraiment très beau et le
soir donne un rapport très fort à
versailles il ya un côté comme ça rendez
vous avec l'histoire
dans les deux cas c'est vraiment des
rendez vous en famille les enfants les
deux il ya pas de risque on peut amener
la belle-mère c'est pas toujours facile
pour une exposition c'est moins simple
et là il ya un très familial assez vrai
familiale avec la belle-mère qui a trois
siècles et demi de contact comme ça
entre le public et puis pour toutes ces
représentations la des musiques qui sont
les musiques du temps de louis xiv du
15-16 donc les musiques baroques que les
gens aiment bien de la marche des turcs
de lully à la danse sauvage de rameau
bon et bien voilà on se fait plaisir
dans du patrimoine tout en faisant une
très belle balade dans un jardin
extraordinaire
ben je vous propose de regarder un petit
extrait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors il ya aussi les fat galante
alors les fêtes galantes c'est un cadeau
qu'on fait au public
il ya en france et à l'étranger aussi
beaucoup de gens qui sont passionnés de
costumes donc dont le trip c'est de se
costumer alors en louis seize ans marie
antoinette en grand gentilhomme mais en
ayant souvent réalisées soit payé des
gens qui passent il re année un
convecteur plus que l'euro n'est
d'ailleurs oui pour l'incroyable bévue
et des styles de cardinal alors non
seulement il ya le costume mais il ya
l'ensemble de ce qu'on va appeler la
parure la manière de se maquiller
perruque et donc c'est beaucoup de
travail et il aime se retrouver entre
eux par définition il faut saluer une
assemblée et le lieu dont ils rêvaient
tous c'est à versailles
or la visite du château de versailles
n'est pas autorisé en costumes notamment
principe
à balad a absolument jamais ray sauf ce
soir là et là pour ces fêtes galantes
qui sont dans l'ensemble de
l'appartement du roi mais on est aussi
on va dans l'opéra on va dans la
chapelle eh bien il n'ya que des gens
avec des magnifiques costumes que de la
musique de cette époque là et ils
peuvent ainsi alors la fois essayer des
jeux comme à l'ancienne le lansquenets
faire des essais de danse baroque s'ils
ne savent pas le faire écouter de la
musique des petits concerts même de
l'orgue à la chapelle et une fille née
faire tous ensemble a pas de danse
galerie des glaces
alors c'est une soirée de rêve qu'elle
soleil on sait comme ça qu'elles soient
les costumes les plus prisées ce qui est
beaucoup de beaucoup de rois beaucoup
marie antoine rey n'ont pas tant que ça
parce que justement ils ont peur d'être
trop facilement identifiés alors alors
par contre ils sont beaucoup à être bons
d'achat on s'est rarement le peuple
c'est toujours en personnages de qualité
oui et c'est plus sinon il faut jouer
quand même voilà c'est plutôt 18e que
dix septième non d'accord on est plutôt
à l'époque marie antoinette louis 15
still d'ailleurs très riche que à
l'époque louis xiv mais le résultat est
assez éblouissant et l'année dernière
par exemple ici on les a tous réunis
pour une photo finale et ils ont rempli
l'opéra comme à l'époque avec les
costumes et c'est des gens qui viennent
d'un peu partout alors c'est des gens
qui viennent d'un peu partout du monde
entier
des voitures des américains des russes
de toutes classes sociales
clairement c'est un hobby comme un autre
donc c'est pas spécialement parce qu'on
va avoir plus de moyens qu'on va se
payer un beau costume de roi c'est plus
par définition une volonté c'est
vraiment comme le train électrique ou de
collectionneurs de modélisme c'est
vraiment c'est une passion c'est une
passion absolue comme vous le disiez il
ya des gens qui achètent mais il ya
aussi des gens qui confectionnent
eux-mêmes qui passe voit leur temps leur
hobby à faire ce à quoi oui ce sont de
vrais costumes à la différence comme ils
disent des costumes louer oui c'est ça
la différence
voilà la réponse a est ce que pardon
hein mais si on est curieux de voir ça
est-ce qu'on peut aller voir ces fêtes
galantes sans être construit soi même
alors non on peut pas rayer jeu il faut
être soi même et ses impôts par ailleurs
non voilà on peut les voir à l'extérieur
avant qu'ils arrivent bon mais c'est pas
pareil
et ça je crois que vraiment c'est
important il n'ya pas là de spectacle
c'est plutôt se respecte c'est le
plaisir dès lors il y a des moments de
spectacle bien entendu pour fournir mais
ils sont eux mêmes au regard des autres
et c'est vraiment très beau alors autres
autre moment qui est aussi très festif
et costumes et c'est justement le bal
costumé alors le bal masqué parce qu'il
est un peul inverse de ça c'est à dire
souvent ce ne sont pas des gens qui ont
fait eux mêmes le costume c'est vraiment
ri c'est déjà si loin et on le fait dans
l'orangerie quitte cette espèce de
cathédrale pour les plantes construite
par le nos immenses sublime somptueuse
et là par contre la musique n'est plus
du tout celle du xviiie siècle donc là
on a le droit d'être habillé peut-être
pas en cosmonaute mais on peut être en
retard de napoléon a pas de contrôle de
là il ya un contrôle sur le costume je
reconnus mais pas sur la typologie du
costume donc l'essentiel c'est qu'on
viennent s'amuser costumé et masqué dix
masques et surtout vous avez parce que
c'est embrassez qui vous voulez il faut
le marais et là on est plutôt sur 2500
personnes et sur des musiques vraiment
d'aujourd'hui mais c'est michael
canitrot qui fait le dj s et hakim
ghorab qui fait les chorégraphies mais
parce qu'il était danseur c'est plus un
très grand choix là et on est peut-être
plus auxquelles on participe peu voilà
voilà on est plus dans le monde ou de la
télé ou du grand show audio visuelle
d'aujourd'hui que dans la constitution
du 14 là c'est tout l inverse
ce qui fait que ça permet à un autre
public qui viendra uniquement en costume
pour une soirée de fête d'être là et
d'être comme d'ailleurs à l'époque
c'était une course très jeune et les
cour de louis xiv ou du karité des cours
de change and on aurait on mourrait pas
vieux tous étaient des militaires qui
avaient envie de s'amuser et leurs
femmes aussi donc c'était de cours qui
avaient des habitudes de fait très
régulière et la fête le bal masqué
commencé à minuit
ah oui oui c est ce qu on fait se passer
quand même c'était voilà donc on va
c'est un public jeune c'est un public
jeune oui c'est tant mieux allez on dira
du 25 45 et
c'est finalement une belle cible de
public souvent ils ne sont pas revenus
au château de versailles depuis qu'ils
étaient à l'école puisque vous parliez
de musique plus moderne il ya aussi
versailles électro alors ça c'est quoi
c'est une nouveauté parce que je crois
que l'électro a conquis aujourd'hui ses
lettres de noblesse notamment en france
qui est la patrie presque de la grande
électro internationale
et là on propose ce projet d'être au
pied de la galerie des glaces dans le
jardin et d'écouté des des grands
maîtres de l'électro alors je ne peux
pas révéler aujourd'hui le nom du futur
a on peut pas révéler c'est un instant
donné et qui viendront devant devant une
quinzaine de milliers de personnes comme
l'an dernier et ça fait un résultat
assez extraordinaire le public l'a aussi
vient du monde entier
bon on n'a fait qu'une première édition
ça sera la seconde mais je crois que là
il ya le côté le début de l'été les
blessés c'est une soirée qui cette fois
ci regroupent plutôt un public un petit
peu plus jeune on est entre 20 et 40 et
surtout d'un public qui a priori ne va
pas venir au château de versailles pour
le visiter mais qui va venir parce qu'il
a il a une occasion d'écouter un grand
groupe électro dans un lieu qui n'aurait
pas du tout été fait pour la prière mais
c'est un peu le point commun de toutes
ces événements c'est à dire qu on peut
il ya évidemment dans versailles à
château il ya le gall ya l'opéra et puis
il ya tous ces spectacles qui permettent
à un public que pas forcément un public
féru d'histoire mais de venir s'amuser
de venir se divertir devenir ce que
ledit vais aussi c'est un peu ça le leur
et je crois que c'est dans l'idée de
l'idée commune ça va être de trouver
pour un public qui ne viendraient pas
normalement pour être visite qui est
moins amoureux de l'histoire ou du
patrimoine ou des expositions
une manière de service au château
aujourd'hui et aujourd'hui si louis xiv
est aujourd'hui il reste comme emmanuel
macron et fera les frais des soirées
électro bon donc faisons de l'électro à
versailles et d'autant que ça ne détruit
pas le château c'est bon la techno c'est
un peu vrai mais on est très loin des
rêves partie des années 90 la la soirée
électro c'est un truc bienvenue entre
gens bien mis et qui sont très calmes
donc on ne détruit pas le château par
contre on lui donne une vie
d'aujourd'hui pour un public
d'aujourd'hui
et en plus la musique ou les fêtes
costumées ou l'électro ça permet à un
public tout à fait internationale de
venir n'y a pas de question de l'enilia
me lancer dans l'apprentissage de
connaissances pour tous ces publics là
c'est une manière d'ouvrir les portes du
musée
et si je suis venu peut-être j'y
reviendrai un autre moment en famille
avec mes enfants et aujourd'hui ouvrir
le patrimoine c'est aussi louvre et
d'autres manières à d'autres publics
c'est bien la preuve que versailles et
eternal c'est ça et que ça doit
continuer merci beaucoup le robot d'air
merci patrice
[Musique]